so right over here i have a flower and i  have a ruler  and what i want to do is figure out how  wide  this flower is so you can pause the  video and think about how i would do  that  all right now let's do this together so  if i want to figure out how wide the  flower is first i could say all right  the left side of the flower goes about  this far  so actually let me draw a line here just  so we can really keep track of how far  we go to the left  and then the right side of the flower  goes about  that far so let's keep track of that and  then we can use  our ruler to measure the distance  between those two lines  we can rotate it a little bit and then  i'm going to move it a little bit and i  want  the left edge of the ruler to start at  that left line  so it's starting right over here and  then we could see  that it's one two three inches roughly  to get us to the right side so it looks  like  this flower right over here is  3 inches  wide